[موسيقى]
الهمت لمساته اجيال من من عشق الكره وهم
يشاهدونه امام لعب معه او ضده فقد وصفه
باعظم من داعب المستديره
او الجوهره السوداء يودع الدنيا بعد ان
خسر مقابلته الاخيره مع السرطان عن عمر
نهز 82 عاما
ان كانت كره القدم
[موسيقى]
ولم يتجاوز 17 ربيعا ولم تخسر معه
البرازيل بعدها كاسا الا تلك اليتيمه التي
توجت بها انجلترا
الاسطوره بيليه سجل باليمنى واليسرى
وبالراس بلغت اهدافه طيله مشواره
1274 هدفا رقم لم يبلغه لاعب بعده
[موسيقى]
عام 1940 في كاراكس جنوب البرازيل بدا
مداعبه الكره في غير بعيد في نادي سانتوس
ولم يلعب لغيره الا بعد عودته من الاعتزال
عندما شد رحال الى نيويورك الامريكي اصوله
الا ان الجميع اراد لمسه قبل مواجهته
وبيعتراف القائمين على الكره الامريكيه
وصول اليه الى البلاد كان كفيلا بتطوير
الكره في بلد العم سام
بيليه اسطوره برازيليه بقي بعيدا عن
السياسه وين اقترب في شبابه من اليسار
البرازيلي ناضل من اجل اطلاق سراح السجناء
السياسيين ايام حكم العسكر بيليه كرر
طلاقه بعالم السياسه عندما طالب
المتظاهرين خلال احتجاجات عام 2013
بنسيان المسيرات وتشجيع المنتخب البرازيلي
[موسيقى]